sair de casa, não tinha roupa para
vestir, não tinha vontade de sair, muita
vergonha de olhar no espelho e tudo
mais. Quando chegou em janeiro, eu junto
com meu marido decidimos que eu não ia
mais fazer nenhum tratamento hormonal,
porque aquilo tava realmente [música]
me prejudicando demais.
Quando eu fui pesar, eu tava com 111 kg,
nunca havia chegado nesse peso. E aquilo
foi muito impactante, olhando foto,
olhando aí nas fotos já era impactante,
quando foi pra balança ficou pior. E aí
nós resolvemos mudar algumas coisas. Eu
tava prestes a fazer 40 anos e eu queria
estar bem para sair nas fotos da festa e
tudo [música] mais. E nós começamos um
jejum por conta, né? A gente viu um
vídeo aqui, outro ali, começamos por
conta. Começamos em fevereiro, em maio
eu consegui chegar aos 98 kg. Eh, tava
bem, graças a Deus, tinha passado muito
bem tudo, porém entrei no momento platô,
né? Não, não perdia, não ganhava, mas
também não perdia. Quando foi entre
junho e julho, eu já comecei a ganhar de
novo, porque aí veio a compulção
alimentar, eu voltei a comer as coisas
que eu comia antes de entrar no período
de jejum.
Eh, e aí eu resolvi, falei: "Não, tem
que mudar, tem que fazer alguma coisa
diferente, porque a minha meta é 30 kg
até [música] o final do ano, né? Chegar
aos 80.
>> Eu tava com indicação de pique e eu não
queria tomar. Nunca imaginei que eu
pudesse aprender [música] tanta coisa em
apenas uma semana e até mesmo descobrir
o porquê de eu não conseguir emagrecer,
de ter muitas, muita vontade de comer
[música] doce, muito sono, muito cansaço
durante o dia. Bom dia. Meu nome é
Juciele, eu tenho 42 anos, eu tive um
problema de saúde há um ano e 8 meses
atrás eu terminei minha quimioterapia.
[música] Eu tive um câncer noário. Eu
ganhei 15, 16 kgos medicamentos, por
todo o tratamento.
>> E meu nome é Juliana, eu sou [música] de
Petrópolis, eu tenho 1,5 m, cheguei a
110 kg. Então assim, é muita coisa. E eu
falei com o meu esposo: "Nossa, se a
gente não mudar agora, daqui pra frente
vai ser ladeira baixo."
>> Olá, eu sou Maria Eugênia, tenho 47
anos. Resolvi entrar no desafio do Dr.
Renan porque
muitos anos da minha vida eu sempre
busquei estar melhor com saúde, com mais
vitalidade, chegar nessa fase que eu
estou hoje dos 40 anos com mais
disposição, podendo aproveitar melhor a
vida. Não é só sobre beleza. Eu me
importo muito com a minha saúde e estar
acima de 70 kg. Eu tenho 1,61, eu me
sinto [música] pesada, eu me sinto mal.
É, fora todas as outras coisas,
articulação.
Para mim era assim, é realmente um
sobrepeso, né? É algo que nunca me fez
bem. É entrar nas coisas, nas [música]
calças, nas roupas todas apertadas. Eu
sempre vesti 38
e hoje eu visto 42. Então isso me
incomoda muito, sim,
>> e com certeza foi a melhor,
a melhor decisão que eu tomei. Eh, eu
comecei o desafio com [música] 100.8
e hoje eu tô com 96,5
após 6 dias, cinco, né, que a gente tá
entrando no sexto. Eh, então foram 4,G3
eliminados. Fora toda a melhoria no
sono, melhoria no cansaço.
>> Quero saúde, quero estar ótima. Então,
emagreci 3, kg até agora
>> perdi 4,5 kg. Me sinto muito melhor
[música] de saúde, não tenho aquele
cansaço, me sinto mais disposta e a
vontade [música] de comer doce quase que
zerou.
>> E eu pesei, eu perdi 3, kg. E assim, eu
percebi já na roupa. Depois do terceiro
dia entrou uma calça minha que não tava
entrando [música] mais. E eu quero muito
participar, quero muito, porque eu já
tenho isso na minha cabeça, que eu
preciso cuidar [música] da minha saúde,
não só em fim estético, mas toda essa
parte fisiológica minha. Eu preciso
cuidar porque eu quero viver mais uns 40
anos. Aí [música]
>> eu perdi 3,2. Hoje é sábado de manhã e
eu tô muito feliz com o meu resultado
até o sexto dia, até sábado. Hoje foram
3 kg eliminados. Eu iniciei o desafio
com 71,5,
71,100. E hoje me pesei agora pela
manhã. assistindo a aula. Estou com 72
kg. Essa semana tô me sentindo leve,
ativa, a minha enxaqueca. Eu só tomei um
dia uma nealdina. Não foi necessário.
>> Depois de ter tentado muitas dietas,
conversado com bastante nutricionista,
primeira vez que eu consigo resultados
assim palpáveis, perdidos 5 kg. É bem
feliz assim de me livrar das 5 kg.
Barriga não tá mais inchada. intestino
tá funcionando bem, sono melhorou, tinha
uma irritação assim de quase querer
matar um na rua e tô calma, calma.
Apesar de estar em jejum, sem comer aí
quase 20 horas, tô assim numa calma eh
que há muito tempo eu não me via e sou
grata aí assim por ter recebido essa
bênção de encontrar o Dr. Renan no
Instagram. O meu organismo tá mais leve,
eu tô me sentindo mais leve, meu sono tá
mais gostoso, o meu intestino tá
funcionando, tinha bastante problema de
gases, não tô sentindo mais isso. O
corpo realmente respondeu de forma muito
positiva. Tão feliz que eu tô até
chorando aqui, emocionada
porque eu fui pesar agora. Eu achei que
no máximo era 4 kg que eu deveria ter
eliminado, mas foram 6,300.
[risadas]
Sabe o que é isso? 6300, doutor.
[roncando] Eu não tô acreditando ainda.
Bom dia, bom dia, bom dia, bom dia,
meninas. Ótimo dia para todo mundo.
Sejam bem-vindas à nossa aula dois. E
vocês acabaram de ver, né, algumas
algumas alunas que já passaram por aqui,
fizeram a estratégia que vocês estão
fazendo. E assim, o que que fez com que
elas tivessem resultados assim? Você
entender que o nosso desafio do jejum,
ele não é só dieta, ele não é só jejum.
Você tem que entender que esse desafio
que vocês estão participando, gente, ele
vai começar a tratar parte dos problemas
da base hormonal metabólica de vocês,
porque hoje a gente vai começar a
aprender sobre base hormonal metabólica.
Tem um mundo ainda de coisas para vocês
conhecerem, porque ontem a gente teve
apenas a nossa primeira aula. Hoje,
então, nossa segunda aula. Sejam muito
bem-vindas. E gente, coloca aqui para
mim assim, ó, que que vocês, quem é
aqui, quantos quilos vocês querem
perder, não só no desafio, tá? Coloca
aqui nos comentários que eu quero saber,
eu quero saber quantos quilos vocês
querem perder. Teve alguém que falou
aqui: "Nossa, eu senti mais sono depois
do jejum ou senti um pouquinho de
fraqueza". Sabe por que que isso
acontece? Quem tem um grau de
resistência insulínica elevada, você que
tem um grau de resistência, a gente vai
aprender muito sobre resistência
insulínica. vocês vão aprender a tratar
a resistência insulínica, tá meninas?
Então fiquem tranquilos em relação a
isso, porque quando a sua insulina é
alta, se você fica um tempo sem se
alimentar, que que a insulina faz?
Derruba sua glicose. Então você fica com
um pouquinho mais sonolenta, um
pouquinho de fraqueza, dorzinha de
cabeça. Mas hoje vocês fazem 16 horas de
jejum. Amanhã também. A partir de amanhã
acaba esses sintomas. Depois vocês vêm
aqui e me conta. Vocês viram que algumas
delas falaram: "Nossa, eu tenho mais
clareza mental, me sinto melhor". eh, no
final da semana. Por quê? Porque esse
perfil hormonal metabólico, ele começa a
estabilizar, ele começa a regular.
Portanto, sejam muito bem-vindos à nossa
segunda aula e se preparem que hoje,
hoje a gente vai construir a base de
todo o conhecimento dos tratamentos que
vocês vão aprender nos próximos dias.
dos tratamentos que vocês vão aprender
nos próximos dias. Então, aqui, ó, quem
aqui sentiu dor de cabeça, eu vi alguém
falando aqui, coloca pitadinha de sal.
Água, pitadinha de sal. Tem que ser um
sal integral, viu? Não pode ser sal de
cozinha normal, não. Pode ser o sal
rosa, sal marinho, sal grosso, pode ser
e sal negro, tem que ser ou sal integral
mesmo. Tem que ser sal integral, viu?
Então agora cada dia vai ficando mais
fácil. Muitas de vocês já estavam
acostumado com os jejum, muitas nunca
tinham feito jejum. Então, ótimo. Que
bom. A gente tá quebrando, quebrando,
né, esse esse essas essa resistência que
você tem. E quando você se esforça,
significa que você tá saindo da sua zona
de conforto. E isso é muito positivo.
Então tô vendo aqui, muitas de vocês
querem perder 14, 15, 20. Teve uma que
falou 40 kg.
Sal não viu, tem que ser sal integral.
Tem que ser sal integral. Alguém
perguntou aqui. Bom, então sejam muito
bem-vindas e se preparem que hoje a
nossa segunda aula do nosso desafio do
jejum vai ser ainda mais surreal. Tô
vendo aqui, muitas querem, alguém quer
perder 26, 15, 10 kg. [roncando]
E aqui, meninas, deixa eu compartilhar
uma tela aqui com vocês. Então, nossa
segunda aula do desafio do jejum.
Vamos lá. A primeira coisa, gente, quero
agradecer vocês eh por toda a vontade.
Vocês estão entrando com garra, vocês
estão se priorizando. Mais um recado
para as ansiosas de plantão. O seu
resultado ele vai acontecer na soma de
todas as estratégias que a gente vai
fazer ao longo dessa semana. Então não é
para você se pesar, porque muitas aqui,
gente, não é porque você fez um dia de
jejum que seu peso vai cair. Seu peso
vai cair na soma de estratégias. Então
hoje vocês vão aprender o por que essa
estratégia de trocar de dietas, trocar
de metodologia dia após dia, vai fazer
com que seu resultado funcione de uma
forma muito muito melhor, potencializada
e acelerada. E outra coisa,
não é para vocês se pesarem ainda, vocês
vão se pesar lá no final da semana.
Inclusive, eu quero que vocês se
programem, que vocês vão se pesar no
sábado, no sábado. Ou seja, o resultado
de vocês vai ser em em cinco dias, né?
Quase seis dias. É, cinco dias, né?
vocês começar segunda, terça, quarta,
quinta, sexta, sábado, e vocês vão
entender o porque que eu vou querer que
vocês se pesem no sábado. [roncando]
Por isso, meninas, por isso eu te peço
uma coisa,
não ache, ai meu Deus, Dr. Renan, pesei
de ontem para hoje, meu peso não caiu. É
porque a gente tá construindo seu
processo. E se você tem alguma dúvida
aqui ainda sobre jejum e você colocar
aqui no chat, se você colega souber
responder essa dúvida da sua amiga, pode
responder aqui no chat, porque assim, a
gente cria essa comunidade feminina que
se ajuda, que se apoia. Então, ajude as
suas colegas. Mas tudo que você precisa
saber sobre tudo que você precisa saber
sobre jejum tá dentro da plataforma, tá
dentro da área de membros, estão todas
as informações estão dentro dos
materiais. Lembra que eu combinei com
vocês ontem que essas aulas aqui, essas
aulas aqui elas são sobre você, sobre
seu metabolismo, sobre sua saúde. O que
você precisa saber sobre jejum só você
ir dentro da nossa área de membros, vai
lá, acessa os materiais e pronto. Aqui
você vai aprender coisas que não tem lá.
Eu vou te ensinar metodologias,
técnicas, estratégias que não tem lá na
área de membros. Por isso que eu falo, é
muito importante que você assista todas
as aulas, você esteja comigo nas aulas e
ainda tem presentes para vocês que
participam ao vivo da das nossas aulas.
Então, vamos fazer uma breve revisão da
nossa aula um. O que que aconteceu na
aula um? Ontem eu te mostrei as vias de
ativação do seu metabolismo, aquelas
três vias energética, do sono e da água.
Com essas três vias eu já faço muita
coisa acontecendo no seu corpo com
estratégias simples, aplicáveis. E eu te
mostrei a escada do emagrecimento
definitivo. Essa semana a gente tá no
seu resetólico.
É o primeiro degrau da escada pra gente
destravar o seu metabolismo. Te mostrei
os cinco erros que te impedem de
emagrecer e eu te entreguei o mapa e eu
te ensinei a olhar sua pontuação e você
descobriu o seu perfil hormonal. Gente,
vamos lá. Quem aqui descobriu? Quem aqui
descobriu, hein? Quem aqui descobriu o
perfil hormonal? Então, seu perfil
hormonal,
ó, eu te entreguei o nosso mapa de
emagrecimento, vocês preencheram o mapa
do emagrecimento. Essa pontuação, ela é
muito importante porque vocês começam a
achar e e deixa eu falar isso aqui que
eu vou falar agora. É muito sério. Vocês
começam a achar, ó, tô vendo aqui, ó,
prisioneira.
Uhum. Sim. Ó, pontuação altíssima ali,
né? Alguém falou aqui, ó. Perfeito.
Uhum. Pontuação de 34. sobrecarregada.
Isso.
OK.
Então, quero falar uma coisa muito
importante aqui para vocês, que é a
seguinte.
Quando você quando você olha para essa
para esses sintomas e olha paraa sua
pontuação, fica muito claro uma coisa
aqui. Fica muito claro uma coisa. Vocês
se acostumaram a sentir mal. Você tá
acostumada com a sua unha que é fraca,
tá acostumado com o efeito sofono, tá
acostumado com a barriga? você tá
acostumado com o seu cansaço, com a sua
ansiedade.
Isso, gente, esses sintomas que vocês
têm não são genéticos, eles não são só
emocionais. Então, existe um um erro
muito grande de você achar que tudo é
por conta de idade, tudo é por conta de
menopausa, tudo é por conta de
emocional, tudo é por conta de genética.
Isso são desculpas. Você tem problemas
hormonais ou deficiências nutricionais
ou deficiências de vitaminas,
deficiências de antioxidantes
que causam esses sintomas. Então esse
mapa só mostra uma coisa que você
enxerga muito tempo, que você não se
sente 100% bem. [roncando] Então aqui
esse perfil, olha só, você agora sabe o
seu estado de saúde. Se a sua pontuação
menor que 10, saúde em alerta. Se a
pontuação
10 maior que 10, saúde em desequilíbrio.
Se maior que 20, saúde ruim. Se maior 40
saúde muito ruim. E daí você tem um
perfil para cada pontuação. A sentinela
que você tem que ficar de olho, a refém
que você já começa a ter desequilíbrios
hormonais, a sobrecarregada onde você já
tem comprometimento, tríade, insulina,
tireoide, cortisol, que puxa para outros
pontos. E você tem a prisioneira, que aí
é saúde muito ruim, onde você tem um
comprometimento já instalado. E todos
esses perfis a gente consegue tratar e a
gente consegue reverter pontuação. E eu
te entreguei o bônus da aula um.
Lembrando, cada aula tem um bônus
secreto que é um presente. Ontem, ontem
eu te entreguei o elixi dourado
antibarriga e quando você tiver todas
essas peças do quebra-cabeça, no final
você forma esse protocolo, acelera
metabolismo. E lembrando, esses bônus
são liberados para quem está ao vivo na
aula a hora que você preenche a sua
lista de presença. A hora que você vai
lá, assina a lista de presença, vai ter
o link para você baixar no momento ao
vivo. Depois não fica disponível mais. É
para você que tá aqui comprometida
comigo. E que que te aguarda nessa aula?
Hoje eu vou te mostrar os pilares do
sucesso do emagrecimento definitivo. Vou
te entregar a segunda chave secreta. E
essa segunda chave secreta, ela tem
relação com o seu diagnóstico. Hoje você
sai daqui com o seu diagnóstico. Você
vai saber exatamente os problemas
hormonais que estão atrapalhando o seu
emagrecimento de acontecer. Mas primeiro
eu quero agradecer vocês. Ontem nós
tivemos 41.000 1000 visualizações na
nossa primeira aula. E nós tivemos o
nosso post, ó, esses posts aqui de cada
aula,
eles contam pontos na hora da gente
escolher a campeã do concurso que vai
rolar nessa semana. Então vão lá,
caprichem nos posts. Sempre que eu pedi
gente, ó, temos o desafio do post e
vocês foram lá #utenovalor. E quando
você escreve isso, quando você escreve
isso, você manifesta na sua vida, você
começa a se enxergar com outros olhos.
Quando foi a última vez que você falou
para você que você tem valor, que você
escreveu que você tem valor, que você
enxergou que você importa, apesar de
tanta coisa que aconteceu com você?
Então isso aqui para mim tem muito mais
valor quando a gente passa a analisar.
de um ponto não de pedir engajamento.
Gente, eu não preciso disso, tá? Se
vocês forem lá no meu Instagram, daqui a
pouco a gente tem 9 milhões e meio de
pessoas ali. [roncando] Eu não preciso
disso aqui para para engajamento, tá?
Isso aqui não me dá engajamento. Isso
aqui faz parte da construção de
mentalidade dessa semana. Você vai sair
no final da semana com uma mentalidade
sobre você, com uma visão sobre você
muito diferente da que você entrou aqui.
E é isso, esse o poder,
porque mentalidade é um dos pilares
dentro do seu emagrecimento, dentro da
manutenção, dentro da saúde, dentro da
visão de longo longo prazo que eu quero
que você construa sobre você.
Novamente, o desafio do jejum, ele não é
sobre dieta, ele não é só sobre jejum,
ele é sobre você. Você vai sair daqui
hoje com seu diagnóstico, você vai sair
com tratamentos para você, você vai sair
com uma visão sobre a sua saúde que você
não tinha.
Então aqui o nosso desafio, eu sei que
vocês chegaram com uma visão diferente
do que seria o desafio e que bom que eu
tô surpreendendo vocês porque eu li,
selecionei várias das mensagens que
vocês colocaram pra gente. Eu agradeço o
carinho. Vocês fi, nossa, que aula
sensacional. Nunca tinha ouvido falar
sobre isso, não tinha enxergado a partir
desse desse ponto de vista, Dr. Renan,
porque você começa a achar que a culpa
tá só sobre você.
E é por isso que o desafio do jejum
funciona. Ele funciona porque ele não é
sobre o Dr. Renan, ele não é sobre o
jejum em si, ele não é sobre explicação
de calorias, ele é sobre os seus
hormônios, ele é sobre o seu
metabolismo. E por isso que ele funciona
também, porque a gente trata a sua base
hormonal metabólica, o seu insulina, seu
cortisol, melhora a função tireoide, de
fígado, de sono, de intestino. quando a
gente começa a aplicar todas as
estratégias dentro de alimentação,
dentro de suplementação, dentro de
indicação de estratégias nutricionais
[roncando]
para vocês e dúvidas que possam surgir
aqui com o seu jejum, porque eu sei, a
gente pega ali as dúvidas de vocês, né?
E aqui, ó,
eu quero que vocês se preparem, hoje
vocês vão bater 16 horas de jejum e
amanhã 16 horas de jejum. Vocês vão ver
que a partir que a que que a gente tem
que fazer, a última refeição antes de
você iniciar o jejum, ou seja, só a
última refeição do dia, ela não pode ter
carboidrato nesse momento. Por se eu
coloco o carboidrato, a sua insulina,
por mais que seja um carboidrato bom, a
sua insulina vai subir, então demora um
pouco mais para esse horário de jejum
que você tá, digamos, fazer um efeito no
seu corpo. Outra dúvida que surgiu, pode
beber líquido nas refeições? Pode beber
líquido nas refeições, não tem problema.
não vai te engordar, não vai te dar
barriga. Mas se você tem má digestão,
ah, ten, quando eu como dá muito gases,
me dá muita distensão. Então, no seu
caso, não recomendo que você beba
líquido junto com a alimentação. Sabe
por quê? Porque o líquido vai diluir o
suco gástrico e diluindo o suco
gástrico, sua digestão fica mais lenta.
Sobre o sal, quem tá tendo dor de
cabeça? A água pitadinha de sal nessa
água de manhã. Se você tem pressão alta,
não se preocupe, não vai subir. Mas tem
que ser o sal integral. Pode ser sal
marinho, pode ser sal grosso, pode ser
sal rosa, pode ser sal negro, pode ser
flor de sal, sal integral. O sal de
cozinha normal, não.
Exercício físico em jejum, posso fazer?
Pode manter sua atividade física sem
nenhum problema. Vou perder massa magra?
Não vai perder massa magra, gente. 7
dias você não destrói massa muscular.
Mesmo porque o ao longo do dia você vai
ter um consumo de proteína que talvez
você tá até consumindo mais proteína do
que comia antigamente. Posso tomar leite
de vaca? Vocês podem observar que lá na
tabela de substituição nós temos
derivados de leite, mas o leite de vaca
em si não. Por quê? Porque o leite ele
vai ter uma absorção mais rápida do que
quando você consome um produto
fermentado ou um queijo ou um iogurte. E
essa absorção mais rápida, por um
processo bioquímico, faz a sua insulina
subir em quem tem insulina mais elevada.
Posso consumir canela, cúrcuma, própolis
e jejum? Não, isso vai quebrar jejum.
Pode consumir água com limão e jejum?
Não, isso vai quebrar jejum. Posso
consumir água de coco em jejum? Não,
isso vai quebrar o jejum porque tem
caloria a água de coco. Pouca, mas tem
caloria e tem carboidrato. Quebra o seu
jejum. Os seus medicamentos e
suplementos pode tomar jejum, não tem
problema.
Dor de cabeça. Quem tem dor de cabeça
são as pessoas que tm o grau de
resistência insulínica mais elevado.
Quando a sua insulina é muito elevada,
se você tem barriga, vive no efeito
sanfona, se você tá 10 kg acima da sua
altura, você tem resistência insulínica.
Como assim 10 kg acima da minha altura?
Como que você descobre se você tem
resistência insulínica? Vamos fazer uma
conta aqui comigo. Faz uma continha aí
comigo. Presta atenção. O, ó, gente, no
jejum, café, chás, água, chimarrão, pode
consumir jejum sem nenhum problema.
Agora, essas dúvidas estão dentro dos
materiais, tá lá na sua dieta, só você
ler que tá tudo explicadinho lá.
Vamos fazer uma conta aqui comigo. Vamos
lá. Presta atenção. Presta atenção aqui.
Pega sua altura. Vamos supor que você
tem 1,60 m.
1,60 m. Presta atenção. Vamos supor que
você tem 1,60 m. Você vai tirar o um e
fica o 60. Se você tem 1,58 m, tiro um,
pega o 58. Se você tem 1,64 m, tira o
fica o 64. Então faz isso, pega sua
altura e tira o. Sobrou esses dois
números finais,
você vai somar mais 10.
Então, se você tem 1,60 m, pega o 60,
soma mais 10, dá quanto? 70. O 162 m,
pega o 62, soma mais 10, dá quanto? 72.
O 1,58 m, pega o 58, soma mais 10, dá
quanto? 68.
Se o seu peso hoje tiver maior do que
essa soma, você tem resistência à
insulina.
Entendido? Então, se você tem 1,62 m e
você pesa mais de 72 kg, você tem
resistência à insulina. Se você tem 1,64
m e você pesa mais de 74, você tem
resistência insulínica. Ah, tornan,
então se meu peso tá abaixo disso, quer
dizer que eu não tenho resistência
insulínica? Não, não quer. Mas quando tá
acima a gente tem certeza absoluta que
você tem esse problema, que você tem
resistência insulínica.
Se você tem barriga, você tem
resistência insulínica. Se você vive no
efeito sanfona, você tem resistência
insulínica. E quem tem resistência
insulínica tem mais dor de cabeça quando
começa a fazer um jejum. Quando começa a
fazer o jejum. Muito simples. Muito
simples. Então [roncando] agora vocês
sabem, agora vocês sabem. Tem gente
fala: "Ó, meu peso tá o dobro". Meu peso
tá o dobro. É isso. Mas que bom, o
conhecimento liberta. A gente tá aqui
para ter conhecimento, pra gente se
libertar da culpa. Porque a culpa de
você tá acima do peso não é sua. Nós
temos também aqui umas outras dúvidas
que eu quero que vocês prestem bastante
atenção. Meninas,
amanhã eu vou ensinar vocês a tratarem
resistência sulínica, viu? Grava. Amanhã
eu vou ensinar o tratamento completo de
resistência sulínica. Amanhã tem muita
coisa. Ser incrível amanhã. Amanhã a
gente começa a tratar algumas dúvidas,
algumas verdades sobre o jejum
metabólico. Dr. Renão, tem problema de
tireoide? Será que o jejum funciona para
mim? Entenda uma coisa, quando a gente
fala sobre tireoide,
eu preciso de um fígado saudável, porque
os hormônios da tireoide, o T4, a sua
tireoide produz o T4, mas é no fígado
que o T4 vira o T3. Então o jejum
metabólico que vocês estão fazendo nessa
semana, ele melhora a função de fígado,
melhora a conversão dos hormônios da
tireoide. Por isso que funciona
independente, outra dúvida que a gente
recebeu, isso aqui são dúvidas que vocês
mandaram pra gente. Tenho gordura no
fígado, isso atrapalha meu
emagrecimento? Sim. Para você perder
peso, você tem que ter um fígado
saudável. Quando você tem um fígado
doente, se você acorda mais de duas
vezes à noite para urinar, quem é que
acorda mais de duas vezes à noite para
orinar? é o seu fígado que tá
sobrecarregado. Se você tem barriga, seu
fígado tá sobrecarregado. E com fígado
sobrecarregado, você piora resistência
ulínica, piora cortisol e diminui
conversão dos hormônios da tireoide. E
esse jejum que vocês estão fazendo
começa a tratar seu fígado, então vai
melhorar todo esse perfil hormonal.
Ah, tor Renan, mas depois que eu
emagreço, eu recupero tudo de novo. Será
que dessa vez é diferente? É diferente
porque a gente não tá só fazendo dieta e
contando caloria. Cada dia que vocês
estão passando aqui, vocês estão
otimizando perfis metabólicos, melhora
fígado, cortisol, insulina, sono. E a
gente vai trabalhar em todos esses
esquisitos aqui.
E vocês vão entender ao longo da aula de
hoje isso que eu tô falando sobre
hormônios. Ah, mas eu tô na menopausa,
depois da menopausa não fica tudo mais
difícil? Meu corpo, será que responde
depois da menopausa?
Pelo amor de Deus, gente, tira isso aqui
da cabeça de vocês. Menopausa não impede
ninguém de emagrecer. Menopausa não
atrapalha ninguém de emagrecer. Só que
quando você entra na menopausa, o que
que acontece? Você começa a acumular
gordura na barriga. acumulou gordura na
barriga e você não cuida, altera
cortisol, insulina, fígado e vai piorar
o seu sono. Então você engorda por essas
alterações metabólicas, o seu
metabolismo que acontece e não por conta
da menopausa. Porque se fosse assim,
quem fizer, quem faz reposição hormonal
emagreceria. Tem alguém aqui que faz
reposição hormonal, hein? Tem alguém
aqui?
Quem aqui?
Tem alguém aqui? Gente, não pode. Alguém
perguntou, não pode. Eu falei isso
ontem, não pode. Canela, cravo,
própolis, no período de jejum. Depois
que você fez primeira refeição, pode.
Alguém aqui faz, ó, tem aqui, ó, gente
que faz reposição hormonal, várias
pessoas. Se você fizesse reposição
hormonal e te emagrecesse, então a culpa
seria a menopausa do seu sobrepeso. Só
que você faz reposição hormonal e não
perde peso. Então essa não é a culpa.
Essa não é a culpa, entende?
Então a gente precisa cuidar de tudo que
envolve o que acontece no seu corpo
independente de menopausa. Ah, torre não
retirei a vesícula, posso fazer mesmo
assim? Sim, com certeza. O jejum, quando
você retira a vesícula, você passa a
envelhecer mais rápido e engorda, ganha
barriga, porque você passa a ter
deficiência das vitaminas A, D, E, K e
se você não repor, você vive menos. Mas
a gente vai falar lá no final da semana,
a gente vai falar sobre reposição das
vitaminas para tudo na sua saúde,
inclusive vesícula. Se não me engano, a
nossa aula de sábado, eu vou falar tudo
sobre suplementação, tudo sobre
suplementos.
Meus exames estão normais, mas o meu
corpo não responde. Por quê,
[limpando a garganta]
gente? Só vai alterar os seus exames
quando o problema já se instalou. Talvez
você ainda tá aí no seu perfil
sentinela, você tá no perfil refém,
sobrecarregada e você não tem alteração
de exame. Seus exames parecem estar
normais porque os médicos olham por
aquele parâmetro de normalidade de
laboratório, mas aquilo lá é uma forma
burra de olhar os exames, só que não
perguntam como você se sente.
Não perguntam como você se sente. Então,
seus sintomas me falam muito mais sobre
você do que os exames. Lembra que eu
falei ontem do meu professor Cícero que
falava: "A clínica é soberana". Os seus
sintomas clínicos me falam muito mais
sobre você do que qualquer outra coisa,
inclusive sobre os exames. Ah, tor
diabetes, pressão alta, colesterol alto?
Posso participar? Com certeza. Por que
que você tem diabetes? Por que que sua
glicose é alta? É uma doença alimentar.
Por que que seu colesterol tá alterado?
Doença alimentar. Por que que você Claro
que quem entra na menopausa, o
colesterol sobe um pouquinho, mas isso é
uma conversa que a gente vai ter no
final da semana. Você que tem pressão
alta, porque você tá com o distúrbio
síndrome metabólica, você tá acima do
peso e à medida que você emagrece,
melhora fígado, melhora a função, repõe
vitaminas, faz uma uma estratégia
anti-inflamatória,
regula perfil de glicose, de colesterol,
de pressão e você se liberta de
medicações. Ah, eu já faço jejum
intermitente há muito tempo, mas esse
jejum é diferente para mim? é totalmente
diferente, porque uma coisa é você ficar
todo dia sem tomar café da manhã, uma
outra coisa é você ter estratégia
pensando em controle de insulina,
aumento de horários de jejum, oscilação
de estratégia dia após dia, porque isso
se chama ciclagem de dieta, ciclagem de
estratégia. E vocês vão entender o poder
disso hoje ao longo da nossa aula.
Então, é totalmente diferente de tudo
que você faz. E um outro erro que você
comete é achar que você pode fazer jejum
para sempre.
Não, você tem que trocar de estratégia
de tempos em tempos, porque independente
da da estratégia, o seu corpo vai se
adaptar a isso.
E depois de quanto tempo eu vou sentir
diferença? Essa estratégia foi desenhada
para 7 dias. Então vocês vão se pesar no
final da semana. Inclusive, eu quero que
vocês se pesem no sábado, mas ao longo
da semana eu vou explicar porque que eu
quero que vocês se pesem no sábado,
porque a gente tem um concurso rolando e
aí eu preciso que vocês se pesem no
sábado para vocês poderem participar do
concurso.
Então vocês vão começar a sentir
diferença mesmo de hoje para amanhã na
eh amanhã, quarta-feira, você já começa
a sentir diferença de quarta para quinta
mais. Então a gente vai evoluindo.
[roncando]
Vou sentir fome e fraqueza. Quem tem
resistência insulínica pode ter esses
sintomas nos dois primeiros dias, mas a
partir de amanhã insulina começa a
estabilizar e você tem um controle
melhor de fome. Ah, mas eu já tentei de
tudo e nada funcionou. Por que que
comigo vai ser diferente? É porque você
tentou só dieta, só remédio e você não
tentou fazer o básico, que é cuidar e
descobrir dos seus problemas hormonais.
O mapa do emagrecimento que vocês
preencheram hoje, a gente vai analisar
esse mapa. você vai sair com seu
diagnóstico daqui. Então esse mapa do
emagrecimento, ele vai trazer um
diagnóstico que nenhuma consulta médica
trouxe para você. E por isso que você
vai entender, nossa, por isso que eu
tentei tanta coisa e não deu certo,
porque não é só dieta. Eu tenho que
pensar em metabolismo. Não existe
gordinho saudável, não existe mulher que
tem barriga saudável.
Ah, mas meus exames deram normais. Quem
tá olhando seus exames? é pelo parâmetro
de normalidade. Então começou, já
começaram te analisando de forma errada.
Ah, mas eu não tenho tempo. Minha rotina
é uma loucura.
Eu tô aqui para simplificar sua vida e
não para complicar.
Você tem que estar aqui uma hora comigo
todo dia, uma semana. Eu acho que você
consegue separar uma hora para estar
aqui comigo todo dia para no final da
semana você não só ter conhecimento
sobre jejum, mas ter conhecimento sobre
a sua saúde, seu metabolismo.
Ai, Dr. Renan, mas eu tenho medo de
emagrecer e recuperar tudo depois. Eu
sei porque que você tem medo. Porque
você tá traumatizada. Isso já aconteceu
tantas vezes com você que você realmente
tem medo. O medo ele vem a partir de
trauma.
Mas eu te digo uma coisa, se você
construir o emagrecimento da forma
certa, você não vai ter reganho de peso.
Só que você só quer fazer dietinha de
qualquer jeito, cortar carboidrato, você
só quer comer pouco, quer tomar remédio
e às vezes você segue esses esse comete
esses erros com acompanhamento.
Mas não é isso que a gente vai construir
aqui. Ah, mas eu tenho compulsão, ataco
a geladeira. Será que vai dar para certo
para mim essa estratégia? Vocês vão ver
que à medida que vão passando os dias e
a gente aumenta o jejum, você passa a
sentir cada vez menos fome, porque a
insulina começa a cair, o seu corpo
começa a utilizar gordura corporal como
fonte de energia.
E será que eu vou dar conta sozinha?
Você não tá sozinha. A gente vai estar
com você aqui todos os dias. Essa não é
uma jornada que você tá sozinha.
Entendido?
Então, todas as suas dúvidas, elas têm
respostas, mas você vai ter que fazer
sua parte. E para você fazer sua parte,
eu quero que você entenda agora sobre os
pilares do sucesso do emagrecimento
definitivo.
Os pilares do sucesso do emagrecimento
definitivo. Então isso tudo que eu falei
aqui com vocês são dúvidas que vocês
mandaram pra gente em relação a esse
nosso protocolo de jejum. Mas
sem construir emagrecimento pautado
nesses três pilares que eu vou te
mostrar, não adianta. Você vai continuar
nadando, nadando, nadando e morrendo na
praia porque você acha que o problema é
sua idade. Vem aqui, gente. Presta
atenção aqui, todo mundo comigo. Quem é
que acha que o problema do seu sobrepeso
é idade? Alguém é que acha que o
problema do seu sobrepeso é idade, hein?
Alguém é que acha que é idade?
Menopausa. Ah, tan, meu problema é
menopausa. Ah, o meu problema não, o meu
problema é a tireoide. Depois que eu
tomei remetiereoide, nunca mais minha
vida nunca mais foi a mesma. Meu
problema é metabolismo lento. Aí vocês
acham que que metabolismo lento é uma
doença ou o problema é o sono.
Eu durmo muito mal, Dr. Renan, por isso
que eu não emagreço. Eu vi um vídeo seu
falando sobre isso. Ou é compulsão
alimentar? Quem é que não consegue
segurar, controlar a vontade de um
docinho ou estress, ansiedade?
Eu já fui no médico e falou: "Ah, porque
eu sou muito ansiosa, estressada, por
isso que eu não emagreço". ou você que
retirou vesícula, porque quem retirou
vesícula passa a ter deficiência de
vitamina A, B, E, K, todo complexo B,
disbiose e para emagrecer tem que repor
tudo isso. Ou você acha que é genética?
Ah, tô aqui em casa todo mundo é
gordinho, então acho que eu sou assim
também por causa de genética. Deixa
[roncando] eu te falar uma coisa.
Eu já fiz meu teste genético. Eu tenho
todos os cinco, cinco genes da
obesidade.
Por que que eu não sou gordo? Por que
que eu não sou obeso? Era para ser
enorme, porque existe uma coisa chama
epigenética. O seu estilo de vida
comanda se um gene vai despertar ou não.
Fibromialgia. Quem que tem fibromialgia?
Quem tem síndrome de ovário policístico?
Ah, não tem muita dor no corpo, acabo
comendo, tomo remédio antidepressivo ou
síndrome de ovário policístico.
Tudo isso são só desculpas.
Sim.
São só desculpas,
só desculpas
que usam,
que jogam em cima de você para você não
conseguir perder peso.
Então, pra gente acabar com todas essas
desculpas hoje, lembrando que cada uma
das aulas eu libero uma chave secreta
aqui para vocês. Cada uma das aulas eu
vou liberando chaves secretas. E essas
chaves secretas, a chave secreta de
hoje, ela tem relação com seu
diagnóstico. Hoje você vai ter um
material que te dá o diagnóstico da sua
saúde, seu diagnóstico hormonal. E só
assim, a partir de amanhã, você começa a
receber todo o seu tratamento para cada
um desses problemas hormonais [roncando]
e aí tudo fica muito mais fácil e aí
você consegue emagrecer de forma
definitiva, acelerada, natural, sem
precisar de outras coisas. Então, no
final da aula, vocês têm a nossa segunda
chave. E para quem tá aqui ao vivo, isso
aqui, gente, é só para quem tá ao vivo,
eu vou liberar o segundo bônus da aula
dois, que é a nossa segunda peça desse
protocolo, acelera metabolismo. E a hora
que você preenche a sua lista de
presenças, que eu libero no final da
aula, você consegue baixar a sua
[limpando a garganta][tosse]
a sua o seu bônus. Surpresa,
OK? Eu vi que algumas de vocês, eu vi
que algumas de vocês falaram que ah, Dr.
Renan, eh, ontem tive algum problema,
não consegui acessar primeiro o primeiro
bônus.
Gente, eu tenho que assumir minha
palavra aqui com vocês.
Só vai receber quem tiver ao vivo e
depois que você preenche, a gente dá um
prazo ali para vocês preencherem a lista
de presença, o link insira. Então, como
algumas de vocês estavam aqui, tiveram
dificuldade de acessar o elixir dourado
que foi liberado ontem, somente hoje,
somente hoje eu vou te dar uma segunda
oportunidade. Quem assinar a lista de
presença no final, você vai conseguir
baixar os dois bônus ao mesmo tempo,
somente hoje. Amanhã não, amanhã não tem
essa colher de chá para vocês. Quem
tiver ao vivo consegue baixar, ok? Então
vocês pediram, teve gente, teve problema
e aí a gente vai dar essa segunda
oportunidade para vocês no final da
aula.
E foi exatamente isso que a gente fez
com a Sandra. Gente, olha a Sandra. A
Sandra é assim, ela tem todo o quadro
igual a maioria de vocês aqui.
Menopausa, não consegui emagrecer,
tentava de tudo, ia em médico, ia em
nutre, tomava remédio.
Indicaram bariátrica para ela, ela não
quis fazer bariátrica. E ela falou: "Ó,
tô Renan, será que para mim tem jeito?"
Ela perdeu 12 kg em 45 dias. Quando a
gente cuida da base hormonal metabólica
que vocês vão começar a aprender hoje.
Gordura no fígado, alteração tireoide,
cortisol, resistência insulínica, menor,
todos os problemas, fígado alterado.
Então, quando a gente trata, o seu corpo
responde: Gente, olha a cintura,
barriga.
Então, não use menopausa e idade como
desculpa. Eu quero que vocês prestem
atenção no caso da Diana. A Dayana,
resistência ulínica, hipotiroidismo, não
emagrecia, mesmo fazendo dieta, fazendo
atividade física, não conseguia perder
peso. Falei Daana, você precisa repol T3
e você precisa tratar resistência sulía,
ela tinha ovário policístico. Quem tem
síndrome de ovário policístico, isso
significa que o seu grau de resistência
insulínica é muito maior. O que que é
resistência insulínica? Quando você come
carboidrato, pão, massa, sobe isso aqui
de glicose e deveria subir isso aqui de
insulina para baixar glicose. Só que
você que tem resistência insulínica,
quando você come um pão, você passa a
produzir muito mais insulina do que do
que deveria. E quanto mais sobe a sua
insulina, mais te engorda, porque
insulina estimula gordura corporal. E
quem tem ovário policístico, o grau de
resistência insulínica é muito pior,
porque a causa de ovário policístico não
é uma doença no ovário, é a resistência
à insulina. E eu falei, Dayana, a gente
precisa cuidar de você
tratando sua tireoide e
tratando resistência ulínica, que tudo
vai melhorar. Só que nessa época aqui eu
não sabia de uma coisa. A Dayana tinha
um sonho de engravidar e ela não
conseguia engravidar e os médicos
falavam para ela, sabe o quê? Que a
culpa era do ovário policístico, que por
isso que ela não engravidava.
E aí eu recebi essa mensagem da Daan.
Gente, eu quero falar uma coisa aqui
para vocês que nada é por acaso. Ninguém
tá aqui por acaso. Eu acredito muito em
sinais de Deus.
Eu sempre fui muito ligado em sinais que
Deus colocava na minha vida. [roncando]
E vocês não estão aqui por acaso. E eu
recebi essa mensagem da Di Daana.
Ela me falou: "Doutr. Renan, perdi 28
kg".
Ela me mandou num direct no Instagram
isso daqui. Depois que eu perdi 28 kg.
Fui sua aluna do PEF, fez o meu, fiz o
meu checkup e o ginecologista, olha lá
que ela escreveu, o ginecologista falou
que meus ovários estavam limpos, que a
síndrome de ovário policístico tinha ido
embora como se fosse um milagre.
Aí o ginecologista fala assim: "Nossa, o
milagre, sua síndrome de seus ová ovário
tá limpo,
seus hormônios regularam como milagre".
Não é milagre, é entender de fisiologia,
é entender de bioquímica. E quando a
gente cuida disso, o seu corpo responde,
seu metabolismo funciona, você queima
gordura, regula seus hormônios, a
menstruação dela regulou, aos 40 42 anos
de idade, ela conseguiu engravidar de
forma natural.
E ela já teve o bebê dela, o bebê dela
tá com vai fazer um um aninho agora. Vai
fazer um aninho agora. Glicose
totalmente saudável, gravidez saudável.
Então te pergunto, será que realmente
estão te analisando de forma correta?
Será que realmente estão te analisando
da forma correta?
Sabe? Eh, esse é o esse é o o ponto que
eu quero que eu quero despertar aqui em
vocês, porque só olham exames, falam
assim: "Ah, toma esse remédio aqui e
segue a vida".
Mas existe uma forma de fazer o seu
corpo funcionar para você quando você
entende de bioquímica, de fisiologia, de
nutrição, de endócrino, de nutrologia e
consegue associar todas essas medicinas.
Assim, eu acredito muito nos sinais de
Deus. Ninguém tá aqui por acaso. Vocês
fazem parte do nosso propósito de levar
saúde pro maior. Não só saúde,
conhecimento, né? Porque diquinha de
saúde você pega na internet, mas
conhecimento sobre você, esse é um pouco
mais difícil. Porque a culpa não é sua.
Eu quero que você tire o peso da culpa,
sabe? Deixa eu te perguntar uma coisa
aqui, assim, de verdade, pensa comigo.
Quantos anos você já passou detestando
olhar o espelho, detestando e comprar
uma roupa, detestando abrir o
guarda-roupa e não ter a roupa que você
quer? Eu sei que você passa muitos anos
nisso. Aí você tá num número de roupa
ali que você não queria. Fala assim:
"Nossa, eu tô vestindo aqui 44, 46, 50".
E quando você olha o número, você vai
comprar, você sente você sente que
aquilo, pera aí, o que que aconteceu
comigo? Como que eu deixei chegar nesse
ponto? [roncando] Então a gente, eu fico
pensando assim, né, principalmente vocês
mulheres,
vocês são igual panela de pressão. Sabe
quando vocês eram crianças e tava lá a
panela de pressão lá na cozinha da sua
casa, sua mãe cozinhando feijão, panela
de pressão começava a fazer o barulho
e você sentia o cheiro de feijão na
casa?
E você é igual uma panela de pressão.
Ela tá ali com toda a pressão.
Você tem medo de explodir, mas ela não
explode porque ela foi feita para não
explodir. Ela foi feita para aguentar. E
o problema da mulher é você acha que
você precisa aguentar tudo sozinha. Você
aguenta calada desaforo que você passa.
Você aguenta calada, humilhação. Você
aguenta calada. Todas as vezes que você
se olha no espelho, você não se gosta.
Você tem que cuidar de filho, cuidar de
casa, cuidar de marido. Você trabalha.
Muitas aqui trabalham, algumas eh não
trabalham, mas você tem outras
responsabilidades. Aí você passa a ter
que cuidar de família, cuidar dos seus
pais e você tem que aguentar toda essa
pressão sozinha e ninguém vê o quanto
que você tá com essa pressão, porque
você guarda tudo para você.
Só que você precisa de uma válvula para
essa pressão não explodir. E qual que é
a válvula? vem no seu corpo, vem nos
seus hormônios, vem na sua saúde, vem na
sua tierreoide, vem no seu sono, vem no
seu intestino, vem no seu metabolismo e
você passa se esconder porque a pressão
tá tanta que você precisa criar essa
válvula de escape que às vezes é a
comida e às vezes é uma alteração
hormonal. E muita de vocês mesmo comendo
pouco, tentando, fazendo atividade
física, o peso não cai. [roncando]
E aí você faz uma dieta, faz outra
dieta, você toma mais um remédio, você
faz mais uma estratégia, tenta, tenta,
engorda, emagrece, engorda, emagrece e
você aguenta essa pressão sozinha,
porque ninguém sabe o que você passa. Só
você sabe o que você passa.
E [roncando] você tenta fazer tudo
certo, mas
você vai no médico e ele fala que a
culpa é sua. É por causa da sua idade,
da sua genética, da menopausa.
Então não foi a sua genética, a sua
idade, não foi, digamos assim, como se o
seu corpo tivesse te traído. Não foi seu
corpo te traiu.
Seu corpo tá te protegendo de não
explodir, de não ter. Aí vai explodir
como em um câncer, uma doença autoimune,
uma doença neurodegenerativa,
a explode numa diabetes,
a explode num infarto, uma doença
cardiovascular.
E aí você tem a resposta: guardou por
muito tempo, mas você busca ajuda.
Então, por isso eu digo, você não tem
culpa. Você não tem culpa
porque existem hormônios alterados, mas
não te analisam da forma correta.
Por exemplo, a Márcia, 60 anos de idade,
não perdia peso, só ganhava barriga,
falavam que era menopausa e ela tava
tentando se aceitar. Falei: "Não, de
jeito nenhum, Márcia,
menopausa, é, desculpa,
perdeu 23 kg
sem fazer reposição hormonal, cuidando
da base hormonal metabólica." cuidando
da base hormonal metabólica,
porque eu sou a casa, você tem que você
tem que enxergar sua saúde como uma
casa.
Entenda isso aqui. O que eu vou te
ensinar agora é a base para todo o
conhecimento das próximas aulas. Porque
nas próximas aulas eu vou tratar os seus
hormônios. Você vai ter dica de
suplementos, dicas de tratamento, dica
de alimentação. Mas para eu tratar os
seus hormônios, você precisa hoje ter o
seu diagnóstico que você vai ter e você
precisa ter essa base de conhecimento.
Você, como que você quer sua casa? Você
quer sua casa toda funcional? Sua casa
toda bonita, tudo lindo, funcionando,
maravilhoso,
né? Tudo lindo. Só que se sua casa tiver
com a porta enterrada, você não entra.
Se a janela não abrir, não entra sol,
não entra ar. Fica com cheiro de mofo lá
dentro, tudo úmido. E você quer sua casa
toda linda. Só que para você ter sua
casa linda, funcional, você precisa de
quê? De uma base sólida, porque senão no
primeiro vento vai embora. Você precisa
de paredes fortes, porque não adianta
você querer construir um telhado lindo
da sua casa se não tem parede. Como que
você constrói a casa pelo telhado?
Porque muitas de vocês querem construir
a casa pelo telhado. Você chega aqui,
ah, eu quero emagrecer a qualquer custo.
OK, o emagrecimento é estética, é o
telhado, mas e as paredes? E a fundação
dessa casa, como que tá causa raiz dos
seus problemas hormonais? E aqui, olha,
eu sou telhado. Então, o telhado é
estética, mas eu preciso construir a
base sólida, paredes sólidas, para sua
estética aparecer e você conseguir
manter seu emagrecimento para sempre.
Então, primeiro pilar da casa, que é a
base, que é a fundação, é um termo que
eu falo muito aqui com vocês, base
hormonal metabólica. Se você constrói
seu emagrecimento esquecendo que existe
uma fundação que precisa ser sólida,
tudo vai dar errado.
Então, eu preciso dessa construção, eu
preciso dessa base. O segundo pilar da
casa, que é a primeira parede, se chama
ciclagem de dietas. Qual o erro que
vocês cometem? Vocês querem fazer uma
única dieta? Você pega uma vai lá no
nutri, um nutri legal da sua cidade,
bom, faz um cálculo de dieta
considerando só calorias. Ele não
considera essas hormônios, não considera
o quanto seu metabolismo tá lento por
conta desses hormônios. E ele monta uma
única dieta e você segue aquela dieta
por 3 meses, 2 meses, 3 meses,
vai estnar toda a dieta o seu corpo vai
se adaptar. Então eu preciso troca de
dieta, trocar de dieta, trocar de dieta
antes do seu corpo se adaptar. Isso
chama ciclo de dietas. O que vocês estão
fazendo aqui no nosso desafio é
exatamente isso. Cada dia a gente tá
mudando de estratégia. Vocês vão fazer
dois dias de 16 horas, depois a gente
passa para 18, depois um choque
metabólico de 20, depois a gente fala:
"Tá vendo? Eu tô oscilando estratégia.
Isso causa choques no seu metabolismo."
E o terceiro pilar para você construir
sua estética, mentalidade, porque não
adianta você chegar a querer construir
seu emagrecimento em cima da culpa, em
cima do medo, em cima dos traumas, em
cima de erros. O que aconteceu aconteceu
ficou no passado. E eu preciso que você
tenha uma visão de longo prazo, não só
imediatista dos quilos emagrecidos,
números na balança. Eu preciso que você
queira construir essa mentalidade de
alto valor, de alto amor, de perdão, de
construção de uma vida saudável, de uma
vida plena. Porque eu não quero que
vocês fiquem magras para os próximos 45
dias. Eu quero que vocês fiquem
saudáveis para a vida dentro da base
hormonal metabólica. Esse conhecimento
aqui tem que ficar dentro da casa de
vocês, dentro da cabeça de vocês.
Quem aqui tem exame de tireoide aí?
Exame de TSH.
Pega o se lá seu último exame de TSH.
TSH perfeito tem que tá abaixo de 2,2.
Se o seu exame de TSH tiver de 2.3 para
cima, você não vai emagrecer. Se você
toma, por exemplo, purã, levo sinóide, o
tirox levxina e não repõe o T3 junto,
porque o seu endócrino não sabe fazer
reposição de T3, ele acredita que não,
não adianta, mas muda a vida de uma
pessoa que tem hipotiroidismo, você pode
até perder peso, mas é muito difícil
manter.
Então, quando você tem uma tiração,
alteração de tireoide, ó, tem aqui, ó,
quem que falou aqui, ó, TSH de 5.1, 5.1
Hipotiroidismo. TSH de 5,
hipotiroidismo. TSH de 7.84,
hipotiroidismo.
Eh, TSH acima de 2.2,
hipotiroidismo subclínico.
[roncando]
Subclínico. Então, é, gente, tá ruim,
hein? TSH de 3.6,
hipotiroidismo subclínico. [roncando]
Amanhã a gente começa a tratar, viu?
Então, quando você tem alteração de
tireoide, seu metabolismo fica quê? 50%
abaixo. Você que tem resistência
insulínica, não é que seu metabolismo
fica baixo, bloqueia queima de gordura.
Você que tem cortisol alterado, seu
metabolismo fica 25% abaixo. Quem dorme
mal, o metabolismo pode ficar 25%
abaixo. E quem dorme mal, você perde 50%
a capacidade de queima de gordura. Se
você tem alteração de intestino, seu
metabolismo cai uns 15%. Menopausa idade
é o que vai atrapalhar metabolismo, não,
porque com a menopausa idade surgem
esses problemas aqui. Então, a gente
precisa olhar para isso aqui. E aí tem o
hormônio leptina, que é o hormônio da
saciedade, grelina, que é hormônio da
fome, tem os seus hormônios sexuais. Aí
tem a dopamina, que é o neurotransmissor
da do prazer, a serotonina, que é o
neurotransmissor da felicidade. Quando a
gente fala de base hormonal metabólica,
eu preciso cuidar disso. E eu te
pergunto, você já cuidou disso no
emagrecimento? Não, só vai lá, passa um
remédio, passa uma, passa uma dieta
calculada em caloria para você.
Não é assim que constrói saúde. Vamos
falar sobre ciclagem de dietas. Quais as
dietas nós temos dentro de uma ciclagem?
Tem dieta tradicional, aquela dietinha,
né, tradicional de três em três horas,
equilibradinha, quantidade de
carboidrato. Essa dieta serve para
alguma coisa? Que que vocês acham? Essa
dieta serve para alguma coisa? Que que
vocês acham, hein, gente?
Essa dieta serve para alguma coisa?
Dieta de [limpando a garganta] três em
três horas serve para alguma coisa?
Sim,
eu via que todo mundo acha que não, né?
Não serve. Ah, não, não, não. Sim, todas
as dietas funcionam. Gravo o que eu tô
falando agora para você que é que vai
contra o que um monte de gente tá
falando aí na internet. Quer dizer, vai
a favor de algumas também.
Toda a dieta funciona no momento certo.
Todas as dietas funcionam no momento
certo. O problema é que você quer fazer
só uma. Ah, eu quero fazer só low carb,
quero fazer só jejum. Seu corpo vai se
adaptar a qualquer dieta. O nosso corpo
vai se adaptar a tudo. Se adapta à
medicação que você toma, se adapta à
dieta que você faz. Então, uma ciclagem
de dietas que é faça uma dieta, troca
dieta, troca dieta antes do seu corpo se
adaptar. Eu preciso
oscilar entre estratégias. Vai ter dieta
que você vai ter que comer mais. Vai ter
dieta que você vai comer menos, vai ter
dieta que você coloca mais gordura,
menos carboidrato. Vai ter dieta que eu
coloco mais carboidrato, menos gordura.
E cada uma das dietas tem um objetivo
hormonal. Por exemplo, low carb. Low
carb é fantástica, excelente. Você vai
lá, corta, diminui consumo de
carboidrato, legal, vai reduzir
insulina, muito bom. Só quando você fica
muito tempo numa low carb, seu
metabolismo vai se adaptar e começa a
acontecer uma coisa, o T3, que é o
hormônio da tiroide, cai. O hormônio
ativo da tireoide.
Paraa tireoide funcionar, precisa de um
mínimo de carboidrato. Se você fica
muito tempo em restrição de carboidrato,
diminui função da tireoide e aí você
entra no efeito plato e daqui a pouco
você desperta a compulsão e ganha peso.
E isso não acontece com ciclagem de
dietas. Ciclagem de dietas é um termo
que eu inventei. Isso não existia antes,
há 8 anos atrás. Hoje tem um monte de
gente que me copia, inclusive copia esse
termo que é nosso. Enfim, é uma pena.
Mas bom que mais gente é ajudada, né?
Eh, pensa, vamos pensar pelo lado
positivo. Não dá pra gente pensar também
no lado negativo de tudo. [roncando]
Como que eu criei isso? Eu tava numa
aula num curso de nutrição esportiva e
um professor falou assim: "Quando o
paciente entra no efeito platô estagna,
você pode entrar com esse suplemento,
com esse outro suplemento, com esse
outro termogênico para dar um choque."
Eu já tinha feito isso. Não adiantava.
Termogênico não adianta para sair do
efeito platô. Estimulante não adianta
para sair do efeito platô. Mas ele falou
uma coisa, falou assim: "Porque o
paciente depois de um tempo o corpo vai
se adaptar à dieta, então você precisa
entrar com estratégias". Aí aquilo me
deu um start. Falei: "Pera aí, se toda
dieta o paciente vai se adaptar, então
vou trocar de dieta antes". E eu comecei
a testar e aí os resultados, eu comecei
a ter resultado naquela época em
consultório. Eu não atendo mais
consultório, não atendo mais. Quando eu
atendia, [roncando] gente, minha
consulta era R$ 2.000, tá? Eu não atendo
mais consultório.
Vocês hoje estão tendo acesso a um
conhecimento desenvolvido nos últimos
anos. E aí foi isso daqui. Então, como
que qual que é o ciclo de dietas que
você faz? Esse primeiro, você vai lá,
faz uma dieta restrita. No primeiro
momento é muito legal porque você perde
peso, só que depois seu corpo acostuma e
aí você estagna no peso. E aí depois que
você estagna acontece alguns processos
hormonais do seu corpo que você sobe o
peso às vezes mais do que você tinha. Só
que com ciclagem de dietas não acontece
isso, porque eu antecipo antes do seu
corpo se adaptar, eu troco de dieta, que
é o que acontece aqui, ó. Então eu tô
fazendo uma dieta, ela tá funcionando,
não é porque ela tá funcionando que eu
vou continuar nela, eu vou e troco.
Aí eu causo nessa troca um choque
metabólico. É o que vocês estão fazendo
nessa semana. A gente estava em 14 horas
jejum, passo para 16, depois 18 tô
causando choques no seu metabolismo.
Depois eu troco dieta, troco dieta,
troco dieta e assim seu metabolismo
mantém ativo e seu peso continua caindo
porque seu corpo não vai adaptar a dieta
que você tá fazendo.
Entendido?
Esse é o poder de uma ciclagem de
dietas.
Então, quando você vai num consultório
médico, um consultório de nutrire, você
não vai sair de lá com 12 dietas
desenhadas para você.
E alguém perguntou qual a melhor dieta.
Quinta-feira vai ser quinta-feira, acho
quinta-feira. Quinta-feira eu vou falar
sobre todas as dietas, o detalhe de
todas as dietas, o detalhe de toda a
ciclagem perfeita, porque em uma hora de
aula eu não consigo. Eu preciso ensinar
esses conceitos para que amanhã a gente
começa a tratar hormônios, depois a
gente começa a vai tudo sobre dietas,
todas as ciclagens, viu? É, é uma aula
melhor que a outra.
Só que
aí sobre quanto tempo de cada dieta a
gente vai falar na aula de quinta-feira,
viu, meninas? Então isso aqui é a
diferença. Você não consegue, não existe
um nutricionista que você vai na
consulta dele e você vai sair com 12
dietas.
Não existe.
Mas eu faço isso com as minhas alunas.
Ela sai com mais de 14 dietas.
[roncando]
Mas a gente precisa mudar isso aqui, o
nosso terceiro pilar que é mentalidade.
Então vocês já entenderam que eh a tira
o peso da culpa, sabe?
[roncando] Entenda uma coisa, qual foi a
forma que você se olhou no espelho
semana passada você tava se arrumando e
se olhou no espelho? Pensa aqui comigo,
como que você se olha no espelho hoje?
Se você hoje for lá sem roupa, sozinha,
você com você mesmo, se você olhar no
espelho,
você gosta da imagem que você vê, você
gosta da mulher que você se tornou,
você às vezes pensa: "Nossa, como que eu
deixei chegar nesse ponto? Por que que
eu não cuidei antes?"
Sabe por que você
se fere tanto? Por que que você se
critica tanto?
Porque você acha que a culpa é sua.
Mas vamos entender uma coisa aqui. A
gente veio aqui, é o que eu acredito,
tá? Eu acredito muito em Deus. Eu
acredito muito que a gente veio aqui na
Terra para evoluir como pessoa.
Eu acredito muito nisso que a gente veio
aqui para evoluir, para fazer o bem,
para que o nosso propósito de vida
consiga ajudar outras pessoas. Eu
acredito muito nisso.
Só que sabe qual que é seu problema?
Você é uma panela de pressão. Você acha
que você tem que cuidar de todo mundo e
que você tem que evoluir todo mundo.
Você acha que a sua responsabilidade
evoluir seu marido, evoluir seus filhos,
evoluir seu trabalho, evoluir sua casa,
se preocupa em evoluir seus pais? Nossa,
tenho que cuidar agora dos meus pais. E
você vira uma gerenciadora da vida e
evolução de todo mundo.
Você tá errado. Você veio aqui para você
evoluir como pessoa.
Só que como que você vai evoluir como
pessoa se você não cuida do básico, você
não cuida do seu corpo, você não cuida
da sua saúde,
você quer cuidar da sanidade mental de
todo mundo da sua família. Você quer ter
esse controle sobre todo mundo da sua
família, fazer o bem para todo mundo da
sua família.
Mas e para você mesmo?
Você se critica, você não se olha, você
não se gosta, você não se ama, você acha
que você não tem valor. E isso acontece,
sabe por quê? Por causa de traumas
instalados. E como que surgem os
traumas? A partir de medo.
Então, todas as vezes que você teve o
reanho de peso, você sentiu mal, você
ficou triste, você ficou abalada, você
sentiu frustrada, você se sentiu
incompetente, incapaz.
E essa sensação diminui sua vibração,
ela diminui sua energia, te joga para
baixo
e tudo que te causa dor, te causa
desconforto, sabe o que que vai fazer? O
seu cérebro vai instalar um sistema de
alerta, que é o trauma. O trauma é o
sistema de alerta. Por exemplo, você tá
andando numa trilha no meio do mato e de
repente você encontra uma cobra cascavel
no meio da trilha. Você vai ficar com
medo, você vai correr, você vai gritar,
você vai assustar, porque o seu cérebro
tem aquela informação de que aquele
bicho é perigoso, que aquele bicho pode
te matar.
Então, quando você começa a chegar perto
de alguma coisa que seu cérebro acha que
é perigoso, que causou alguma dor para
você, então todas as vezes que você teve
reganho de peso, gerou uma dor, gerou
uma frustração.
Então, seu cérebro instalou esse trauma,
o trauma de tentar de novo. Quantas de
vocês chegaram aqui com medo? Quantas de
vocês chegaram aqui? Será que o Dr. Ren
vai estar? Será que eu consigo? Será que
vai dar para mim? Será que vai dar
certo? Será que não vai? É o seu cérebro
querendo te afastar daquilo que te
causou um trauma. E por isso que você
tem medo de tentar de novo. [roncando]
Mas eu quero começar a quebrar esse medo
agora,
porque você não tem culpa de ter
problemas hormonais. Você tenta, você
come pouco, você faz dieta, você vai em
médico, você vai em nutre, você já toma
remédio, você já fez cirurgia, você
tenta e você ainda assim acha que a
culpa é sua?
Nesse momento acho que não mais, porque
eu tô te ensinando algumas coisas. Mas
você não escolheu dormir mal, você não
escolheu ter problema de tireoide, você
não escolheu entrar na menopausa e
acumular gordura na barriga e passar a
alterar cortisol, insulina, fígado. Você
não escolheu isso. Mas nós temos que ser
conscientes e adultos. Agora é o adulto
falando, porque quando você faz birra,
ah, não é para mim, ah, não vou fazer,
ah, não dou conta, é a sua criança
interior falando, porque a criança faz
birra, o adulto ele escolhe, OK, escolho
seguir, escolho me abandonar, é uma
escolha, não tem meio termo. O adulto
ele escolhe, a criança faz birra, a
criança ocupa o outro,
a sua criança interna. Nós todos aqui
somos adultos nesse momento porque o
conhecimento te liberta e com a
libertação você tem um direito de
escolha. Direito não, você tem um poder
de escolha. O direito é sempre seu, mas
o poder de escolha vem a partir do
conhecimento. Então, a partir de
[roncando] agora, eu quero que vocês
tenham uma visão de longo prazo.
Você como mulher adulta, OK, eu entendi
que a culpa não é minha, mas eu bato no
peito. Você tem que bater no peito e
falar assim: "Teve vezes que eu me
abandonei,
OK? O que que eu aprendo com essas vezes
que eu me abandonei?
O que que eu vou aprender com essas
vezes que eu me abandonei?
Então, a culpa não é sua. Teve vezes sim
que você se abandonou, que você se
deixou.
E o merecimento de se sentir mais
bonita, de ter resultado, de conseguir
perder peso, o merecimento vai vir a
partir do conhecimento. OK, agora eu
entendo. Eu escolho me cuidar, escolho
me amar, eu tenho valor, apesar do peso
que eu não gosto, apesar do corpo que eu
não gosto ainda,
eu perdoo todas as vezes que eu me
abandonei, que eu escolhi me abandonar e
bola pra frente.
Porque só vai existir o merecimento
quando você se libertar de tudo isso.
Eu quero falar mais uma vez para vocês
aqui, a culpa não é sua.
A culpa é de quem não soube te tratar.
Simples. E não estão sabendo te tratar.
E quando você trata da forma correta,
nesses três pilares, mentalidade, base
hormonal metabólica, ciclagens, dietas,
tudo que você se tinha vai embora. Uma
virada 360º na sua vida e no seu
metabolismo. Lembra daquilo que eu falei
lá? Ah, qual que é a culpa? é tireoide,
menopausa, fibromialgia, sono ruim,
metabolismo lento, estress, ansiedade,
compulsão, genética, e idade. São
desculpas que profissionais colocam
sobre você,
porque a culpa é deles de não saberem
tratar isso daqui, de não saber o repol,
de não saber repos vitaminas para
fibromialgia, fibromialgia você trata
com antioxidante e vitamina, que eu vou
te falar sábado, inclusive sábado eu vou
te falar as vitaminas da vesícula,
vitamina para tudo, tudo, inclusive pra
vesícula. Você não tem culpa de dormir,
dormir mal.
Tudo isso aqui são desculpas.
Eu quero te fazer algumas perguntas
agora. Eu quero que vocês prestem muita
atenção nas imagens que eu vou te
mostrar. Muita atenção nas imagens que
eu vou te mostrar. Vê se você tem isso
daqui.
Oscilação de humor, unha fraca, queda de
cabelo, barriga, efeito sanfona, mãos e
pés frios, preguiça, desânimo, cansaço
que não passam mesmo dormindo. Tem esses
sintomas. Quem é que tem esses sintomas,
hein?
Acorda à noite para urinar. Mais duas,
mais de duas vezes à noite para orinar.
Tem isso daqui.
Você tem esses sintomas aqui, gente? Não
acabou não, tá? Nós temos aqui chave
secreta hoje, seu diagnóstico e vou
liberar o box.
Eu falo: "É próximo, é próximo de 60
minutos, tá gente? [risadas]
É próximo. Você tem esses sintomas aqui,
axila escurecida, viril escurecida,
pescoço, barriga, acne nessa região,
aumento de pelo. Tem.
E você tem isso daqui? Estress,
ansiedade, preguiça, desânimo, cansaço,
compulsão, às vezes alimentar, vontade
de doce.
Você é uma pessoa estressada, cansada ou
estressada com muita energia?
Presta atenção. Então, tem esses
sintomas, tem esses sintomas, tem esses
sintomas.
[roncando]
Se você tem esses sintomas, você tem
grandes alterações da base hormonabólica
e por isso que você não perde peso. E
amanhã, na aula três, eu vou te ensinar
a tratar esses problemas, descobrir a
causa desses problemas e a gente vai
começar a tratar com alimentos,
suplementos, chás. Amanhã na aula três a
gente vai começar a tratar tudo isso. E
foi exatamente o que a gente fez com a
Mariana. A Mariana tinha quase todos
esses sintomas. Ela tinha retirado a
tireoide, um câncer de tireoide. A
endócrina dela falou que ela não
conseguia, não conseguiria emagrecer
mais por causa da do câncer tireoide. Eu
falei: "Mariana, a gente precisa
controlar sua insulina, só tireoide,
repol3 e ela perdeu 14 kg em 45 dias e
ao todo 30 kg e mantendo a 2 anos.
Essa é a diferença de tratar causa raiz.
E pra gente tratar essa causa raiz, essa
causa raiz que eu libero agora para
vocês, a nossa segunda chave secreta. E
essa segunda chave secreta, isso aqui,
você vai ter o seu diagnóstico em cima
do seu diagnóstico hormonal. Amanhã a
gente começa a tratar os seus hormônios,
o seu metabolismo.
Então, segunda chave secreta, radar de
problemas liberado para vocês. O que que
é o radar de problemas? essa ferramenta
que já está liberada dentro da dentro da
área de membros, onde você em cima, eu
preciso da pontuação do seu mapa e cada
ponto do mapa daquele setor, setor 1 2 3
4 5 assinalar nesse radar de problemas a
pontuação que deu e depois você vai
ligar os pontos. Deixa eu te mostrar
como que você vai fazer isso daqui.
Então, olha só como que você vai fazer.
Opa, como que você vai fazer isso? Deixa
eu mostrar, deixa eu mostrar um exemplo
aqui de preenchimento do mapa e
preenchimento do radar, porque eu quero
que todos vocês preencham direitinho,
porque o que que é esse radar? Ele me
traz uma fotografia visual de qual
problema hormonal mais está impedindo o
seu emagrecimento.
Então aqui, então aqui é um exemplo de
preenchimento do mapa. Você vai dar uma
nota de zero a quatro para cada um dos
sintomas. Aí coloquei alguns exemplos
ali, onde quatro você tem muito desses
sintomas e zero você tem zero desses
sintomas. E aí você vai colocar soma do
problema um. Ó lá, ó. Então, setor um,
qual foi a soma? 12. Depois o setor
dois, vou dar alguns exemplos só pra
gente preencher o radar aqui. Coloquei
20, exemplo de 15 no setor 3, 5 no 4 e
10 no 5. Então você vai pegar o setor
um, você vai lá no problema um do radar
de problemas e você vai achar qual foi o
ponto ação que eu coloquei ali. 12.
Então você acha o 12 e você vai
assinalar ali, ó, onde tá mais ou menos
o 12. O 20, você vai achar o 20 no
problema do onde tá o 20?
Fora lá do círculo. Quanto mais para
fora, maior a numeração. 15. Eu acho lá
o 15 e venho no problema 3 e assiná-lo.
Depois eu acho o problema quatro, que eu
coloquei uma nota baixa cinco. Você vai
assinar ali. E o problema 5 nota 10.
Depois você vai ligar todos esses
pontos.
Você conecta todos os pontos e você vai
ter uma fotografia visual dos seus
problemas hormonais.
Ligou tudo? E aqui o mais legal é o
seguinte, quanto mais para fora tá
assinalado esse problema, grava isso.
Quanto mais para fora do círculo tá
assinada, mais para fora no seu radar tá
assinalado esse problema, mais esse
problema tá impactando o seu
emagrecimento, mais esse problema
atrapalha seu emagrecimento, mais esse
problema atrapalha o seu metabolismo.
Entendido? Onde vocês encontram o radar
de problema? Já tá liberado dentro da
área de membros. Mas agora eu preciso te
explicar isso daqui. Isso daqui é o mais
importante dessa aula hoje. Isto daqui.
Então agora eu revelei para vocês o que
que cada setor do seu mapa representa.
Aqui, ó. O que que cada setor do seu
mapa tá representa? Alguém quem não sabe
onde que tá, eu já vou mostrar onde que
tá dentro da área de membros para vocês
aqui. Já já vou mostrar.
Então, o setor um representa alteração
de cortisol. Setor dois, insulina. Setor
3, tireoide. Setor quatro, sono. Setor
CC, intestino. Então, anota isso, gente.
Tira print dessa tela. Tira print da
tela. Tira print. Tira print da tela.
Deu? Tira print da tela. Tira print
aqui. [roncando] Então, setor um,
cortisol, insulina, tirei o editsono,
intestino. Agora você já sabe a relação
desses sinais e sintomas com cada
problema hormonal. Agora você tem o seu
diagnóstico.
Ah, minha pontuação foi mais alta no um,
dois e três. Então você já sabe que onde
tá o seu problema hormonal. E amanhã a
gente vai começar a tratar os seus
problemas hormonais. [roncando]
Entendido? Onde que você encontra?
Quando você entra na nossa área de
membros,
na área de membros vai tá lá, vai ter a
aula um, tem a chave um, aula dois tem
um botão verde e você encontra a chave
secreta dois.
E temos para quem está na aula hoje
liberado o nosso segundo bônus da aula
dois, que é o quê? O chá,
os os chás dos cinco alarmes. Então, o
que que são esses chás dos cinco
alarmes? É isso daqui, ó.
É isso daqui, os chás dos cinco alarmes.
Então, vocês têm cinco alarmes no corpo
de vocês. Novo bônus liberado. Quais são
cinco alarmes? Quais são cinco alarmes?
Nós temos o alarme da insulina.
Da insulina nós temos o segundo alarme,
que é o alarme do metabolismo lento. Nós
temos o terceiro alarme alarme que é
relação insulina fígado. O quarto alarme
que é relação fígado cortisol e o quinto
alarme que é a relação cortisol sono.
Tudo nada no nosso corpo vem separado,
gente. É um efeito dominó. Quando você
derruba um hormônio, ele vai puxando os
outros e aí você não sabe quando começou
o quê, porque você já tá há anos
sentando. Então, temos os chás dos cinco
alarmes. E como você pega esse bônus?
Lembrando, quem não pegou o bônus de
ontem, isso não vai se repetir amanhã.
Só pega os bônus quem tá ao vivo na
aula. Eu te dou minha palavra. Ontem
muitas de vocês não souberam como baixar
o nosso bônus da aula um. Então hoje a
hora que você for baixar o bônus da aula
dois é só para quem tá ao vivo. Você
consegue baixar o bônus da aula um e da
aula dois. Mas amanhã não. Amanhã vai
ser só o bônus da aula três. Temos um
acordo? Então dou minha palavra aqui
para vocês. Como que você pega esses
bônus? Daqui a pouco eu vou colocar aqui
no chat o link para você preencher a
lista de presença, porque nessa semana
temos sorteio e temos concurso. Para
você participar do sorteio e concurso,
você tem que preencher todas as listas
de presenças de todas as aulas. Só assim
você pode participar do sorteio do kit
de suplementos, que eu já vou falar do
kit de suplementos. E quando você
preenche sua lista de presença aqui
comigo ao vivo na aula, tem um link no
final da lista de presença para você
baixar. Mas antes eu quero falar uma
coisa aqui com vocês,
ó. Só preencher a lista de presença e no
final vai ter o link para você baixar o
bônus. Mas esse link só é válido ao vivo
aqui. Depois a gente depois ele inspira.
E eu te pergunto, quantas vezes vocês
foram em médicos e nutres que só fizeram
cálculo de dieta, cálculo de caloria, só
olha os seus exames, fala que tá tudo
bem com você e não analisam seus
sintomas e aí te cobram valor de uma
consulta? Você investe seu tempo, seu
dinheiro e não te entrega um 1/3, um
démo do que o desafio tá te entregando.
E eu te prometi, hoje você ia sair daqui
com a sua análise, você sabe os seus
problemas hormonais. Agora você consegue
se olhar, você consegue se enxergar.
Então, temos o post do desafio no
Instagram, ó. Pera aí.
Eu vou fazer, vou postar essa foto aqui
lá no meu perfil do Instagram
e quem comenta primeiro. Quando você
comenta, a gente tá fazendo esse
trabalho de mentalidade, mas isso aqui
conta pontos na hora da gente escolher a
campeã do concurso que tá rolando nessa
semana. Então eu vou postar essa foto
aqui lá no meu perfil do Instagram que é
@renambanotelhodr.
Meu perfil do Instagram e você vai lá e
escreve para mim. Tem que ser lá nesse
post. #eolho.
Agora eu enxergo que você vai falar os
problemas que você descobriu que você
tem, que você não sabia. # me olho.
Agora eu enxergo que eu tenho X, Y, Z.
Agora eu enxergo isso. Escreve o quanto
essa aula foi legal para você, porque eu
gosto de Eu leio tudo, tá gente? Leio
tudo, quer dizer, tento ler ao máximo
que eu posso. Estão desafiadas no nosso
post do Instagram, #eolho. Agora eu
enxergo aqui, tenho isso, isso e isso. E
isso aqui conta pontos paraa campeã do
concurso e sorteio que vai acontecer do
concurso que vai acontecer a semana.
Temos então no final da semana um
sorteio que vai acontecer na última
aula, ou seja, o sorteio vai acontecer
na aula de domingo, na sétima aula, vai
ser um sorteio ao vivo e quem que
participa? Quem preencher todas as
listas de presença, então vou colocar
que que eu vou sortear meu kit de
suplemento. Isso aqui não tá à venda. Eu
não vendo o suplemento. São fórmulas
desenvolvidas por mim. E essa daqui é a
pílula do pãozinho. É uma fórmula que
atrapalha a absorção de uma refeição
livre. Vai sair com sua família comer
uma pizza? Toma isso aqui antes. É
excepcional. O fitoterápico que ajuda em
energia
e o gelzinho dos sonhos que ajuda na
libido feminina. As alunas piramisso
aqui. Então eu vou sortear ao vivo esse
kit de suplementos. Para você participar
do sorteio, você tem que preencher todas
as listas de presenças de todas as
aulas. E temos o concurso que tá rolando
nessa semana. Lembra que ontem eu pedi
para vocês tirarem foto, foto de antes,
foto de frente, de lado, de costas e no
final da semana você vai mandar pra
gente essa foto com todo não quilos
emagrecidos são importantes para nós,
mas a transformação e vai ter uma tarefa
no final de semana para vocês
participarem do concurso. E o que que
campeã do concurso ganha? Ela vai ter a
análise do mapa do emagrecimento dela
feita individualmente por mim. Ela vai
receber o kit de suplementos em casa e
ela ganha vaga garantida no PEF 360, que
é meu programa de emagrecimento feminino
com meu acompanhamento, meu programa
mais completo que eu tenho, e ela ganha
vaga garantida na próxima turma do PEF
360.
Portanto, não se esqueçam, tem que
preencher todas as listas de presença,
vocês têm que ter tirado a foto, né?
Espero que vocês tenham tirado a foto,
ainda dá tempo. E mais importante,
resultados físicos de saúde amanhã.
Então, na aula três, meninas, amanhã, na
aula 3, 7 horas da manhã, ela é ainda
melhor, porque a gente vai começar a
tratar, vamos aprofundar na base
hormonal metabólica, vamos começar a
tratar os cinco problemas da base
hormonal metabólica para você não só
emagrecer, mas ter mais saúde. Te
entrego a terceira chave secreta e te
entrego o terceiro bônus do protocolo
Acelera metabolismo. A lista de pres, o
link da lista de presença está no chat,
pessoal. Link da lista de presença está
no chat,
OK?
Vamos lá. Essa foto aqui lá no perfil do
Instagram, gente. Foto de vocês. Quem
não tirou ainda, tira foto de frente,
vai no espelho, tira foto de frente, de
lado, de costas. Para você ver a
diferença depois, no final dessa semana.
Link da lista de presença está no chat e
no final você vai ter acesso ao bônus. E
esses bônus são liberados só para quem
tá ao vivo. Então vocês estão aqui
comprometidas, recebem mais uma baita
ferramenta para acelerar o metabolismo
de vocês. O link está aqui no chat.
Acessa o link, vai lá e baixa seus
monos, meninas. Então, beijo. Primeiro,
obrigado pelo comparecimento de todos
vocês. Vejo vocês amanhã na nossa
terceira aula pra gente começar a tratar
todos aqueles sintomas e a sua base
hormonal metabólica, porque agora você
tem o diagnóstico da sua saúde, meninas.
Então, um beijo. Eu vejo vocês amanhã.
Saind de casa, não tinha roupa para
vestir, não tinha vontade de sair, muita
vergonha de olhar no espelho e tudo
mais. Quando chegou em janeiro, eu junto
com o meu marido decidimos que eu não ia
mais fazer nenhum tratamento hormonal,
porque aquilo tava realmente me
prejudicando demais.
Quando eu fui pesar, eu tava com 111 kg.
Nunca havia chegado nesse peso. E aquilo
foi muito impactante, olhando foto,
olhando. Aí nas fotos já era impactante,
quando foi pra balança ficou pior. E aí
nós resolvemos mudar algumas coisas. Eu
tava prestes a fazer 40 anos e eu queria
estar bem para sair nas fotos.Amos
um jejum por conta, né? A gente viu um
vídeo aqui, outro ali. Começamos por
conta. Começamos em fevereiro. Em maio
eu consegui chegar aos 98 kg. Eh, tava
bem, graças a Deus, tinha passado muito
bem tudo, porém entrei no momento platô,
né? Não, não perdia, não ganhava, mas
também não perdia. Quando foi entre
junho e julho, eu já comecei a [música]
ganhar de novo, porque aí veio a
compulção alimentar, eu voltei a comer
as coisas que eu comia antes de entrar
no período de jejum.
Eh, e aí eu resolvi, falei: "Não, tem
que mudar, tem que fazer alguma coisa
diferente, porque a minha meta é 30 kg
até o final do ano, né? Chegar aos 80.
>> Eu tava com [música] indicação de os
pique e eu não queria tomar. Nunca
imaginei que eu pudesse aprender tanta
coisa em apenas uma semana e até mesmo
descobrir o porquê de eu não conseguir
emagrecer, de ter muitas, [música]
muita vontade de comer doce, muito sono,
muito cansaço durante o dia. Bom dia.
Meu nome é Jciele. Eu tenho 42 anos, eu
tive um problema de saúde há um ano e 8
meses atrás. Eu terminei minha
quimioterapia. Eu tive um câncer noário.
Eu ganhei 15, 16 kg pelos medicamentos,
por todo o tratamento. [música]
>> E meu nome é Juliana, eu sou de
Petrópolis. Eu tenho 1,5 m, cheguei a
110 kg. Então assim, é muita coisa. E eu
falei com o meu esposo: [música] "Nossa,
se a gente não mudar agora, daqui pra
frente vai ser ladeira abaixo".
>> Olá, eu sou Maria Eugênia, tenho 47
anos. Resolvi entrar no desafio do Dr.
Renan porque
muitos anos da minha vida, eu sempre
busquei estar melhor com saúde, [música]
com mais vitalidade, chegar nessa fase
que eu estou hoje dos 40 anos com mais
disposição, podendo aproveitar melhor a
vida. Não é só sobre beleza. Eu me
importo muito com a minha saúde e estar
acima de 70 kg. Eu tenho 1,61, eu
[música] me sinto pesado, eu me sinto
mal. É, fora todas as outras coisas,
articulação
para mim era assim, é realmente um
sobrepeso, né? É algo que nunca me fez
bem. É entrar nas coisas, nas calças,
nas roupas todas apertadas. Eu sempre
vesti 38
e hoje eu visto 42. Então isso me
incomoda muito, sim,
>> e com certeza foi a melhor,
a melhor decisão que eu tomei. Eh, eu
comecei o desafio com 100.8
e hoje eu tô com 96,5
após 6 dias, cinco, né, que a gente tá
entrando no sexto. Eh, então foram 4,G3
eliminados. Fora toda [música] a
melhoria no sono, melhoria no cansaço.
>> Quero saúde, quero estar ótima. Então,
emagreci 3, kg até agora
>> perdi 4,5 kg. Me sinto muito melhor em
saúde. Não tenho aquele cansaço, me
sinto mais disposta e a vontade de comer
doce quase que [música] zerou.
>> E eu pesei, eu perdi 3,5 kg. E assim, eu
percebi já na roupa. Depois do terceiro
dia entrou uma calça minha que não tava
entrando mais. E eu quero muito
participar, quero muito, porque eu já
tenho isso na minha cabeça, que eu
preciso cuidar da minha saúde, não
[música] só em fim estético, mas toda
essa parte fisiológica minha. Eu
[música] preciso cuidar, porque eu quero
viver mais uns 40 anos. Aí
>> eu perdi 3,2. Hoje é sábado de manhã e
eu tô muito feliz com o meu resultado
até o sexto dia até sábado. Hoje foram 3
kg eliminados. Eu iniciei o desafio com
71,5,
71,100. E hoje me pesei agora pela manhã
assistindo a aula. Estou com 72 kg. Essa
semana tô me sentindo leve, ativa, a
minha enxaqueca. Eu só tomei um dia uma
nealdina. Não foi necessário.
>> Depois de ter tentado muitas dietas,
conversado com bastante nutricionista,
primeira vez que eu consigo resultados
assim palpáveis, perdidos 5 kg. É bem
feliz assim de me livrar desses 5 kg.
Barriga não tá mais inchada, intestino
tá funcionando bem, sono melhorou. Tinha
uma irritação assim de quase querer
matar um na rua e tô calma, calma.
[risadas]
Apesar de estar em jejum, sem comer aí
quase 20 horas, tô assim numa calma, é
que há muito tempo eu não me via. E sou
grata aí assim por ter recebido essa
bênção de encontrar o Dr. Renan no
Instagram. O meu organismo tá mais leve,
eu tô me sentindo mais leve, meu sono tá
mais gostoso, o meu intestino tá
funcionando, tinha bastante problema de
gases, não tô sentindo mais isso. O
corpo realmente respondeu de forma muito
positiva.
>> Tão feliz que eu tô até chorando aqui,
emocionada
porque [roncando] eu fui pesar agora. Eu
achei que no máximo era 4 kg que eu
deveria ter eliminado, mas foram 6.
Sabe que é isso? 6 300 do [roncando]
Eu não tô acreditando ainda.